[موسيقى]
بربادوس هي واحدة من
وجهات الغولف الأكثر تميزًا في العالم
[موسيقى]
لديها العديد من الملاعب المتميزة
بما في ذلك هذا المكان رويال ويستمورلاند لقد
كنت ألعب بضع حفر مع
اثنين من المحترفين هنا،
سنذهب إلى
اليسار قليلاً وأنت'  لقد كنت هنا
منذ أن كان عمرك أربع سنوات، نعم، لذا
أخبرنا قليلاً عما يجعل بربادوس
مميزة جدًا ولطيفة جدًا، نعم أعني أنني
لن أتخلى عن تجربتي في
نشأتي في بربادوس مقابل أي شيء
استمتعت به حقًا خلال نشأتي هنا.  لقد
كنت محظوظًا حقًا بلعب الجولف معظم
حياتي هنا في رويال ويست بورتلاند،
وهذا في حد ذاته يمثل إضافة كبيرة ولكن فيما
يتعلق ببربادوس، فإن جميع أصدقائي موجودون
هنا وهي مجرد ثقافة رائعة،
فالناس في بربادوس رائعون ويحبونهم
قلت إنني لن ألاحظ أن نشأتي هنا من أجل
العالم هو ما الذي يجعل هذا المكان
مميزًا جدًا للجولف على وجه الخصوص، وأود أن
أقول إنه من العدل أنه يمثل تحديًا أيضًا، لذلك
على سبيل المثال، يعد T أمرًا سخيًا للغاية
ولكن لقطاتك في المساحات الخضراء عبارة عن
بعض الأخاديد و  مخابئ في مكان جيد
ستجعل الأمر تحديًا ولكن
اللقطات الجيدة ستكافأ دائمًا
كيف رأيت بربادوس تتطور
بشكل هائل، لقد كانت دائمًا واحدة من
أكثر الجزر تطورًا في
منطقة البحر الكاريبي
ولكن في السنوات العشر الماضية أود أن أقول إنها
تطورت بشكل كبير
ها نحن ذا، ها نحن ذا
حسنًا، على الأقل إنهم يلعبون لعبة
غولف اجتماعية، نعم
جميل،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، كان ذلك رائعًا حقًا، أحب تمامًا، لقد
كان رائعًا، شكرًا لك، شكرًا لك، لقد كان من دواعي
سروري مقابلتك